et on voit là que les mesures de relance
que ce soit celles qui ont été prises au
niveau européen où que ce soit celles
qui sont prises à l'échelon français
reste très en deçà de ce qui est fait
alors que ce soit en allemagne
que ce soit aux états unis en
particulier donc c'est pour ça qu'on
peut parler d'un risque de déclassement
par rapport aux grandes puissances
quelle croissance cette année en france
avec le troisième confinement bercy a
déjà revu ses ambitions à la baisse sera
5% tout au plus contre 6 5% prévus
jusqu'ici alors dans quelle mesure cette
mise à l'arrêt de pans entiers de
l'économie étaient une menace pour la
reprise ces vents contraires ne
risque-t-il pas de reléguer notre pays
en peloton dans la compétition
internationale
c'est l'objet de l'édito échos ce soir
bonsoir jacques sapir le nouveau
confinement que l'on vit actuellement à
fait l'effet d'une douche froide qu'elle
va en être le coup et quelles en seront
les conséquences pour l'économie vaste
question oui effectivement ce troisième
confirmant que le président macro aurait
bien voulu visiblement éviter
eh bien il va coûter cher à coûter cher
à l'économie alors d'abord il a coûté au
niveau des aides 1 que ce soit le
chômage partiel
le fonds de solidarité il va coûter
aussi en termes de croissance parce que
on peut penser que la croissance
française va perdre l'équivalent d'un
point de pib
et puis évidemment bas il va coûter cher
en perte de revenus fiscaux et donc
c'est trois coups vont s' d'une certaine
manière ce combiné et vont tirer vers le
bas
l'économie française alors jacques tout
d'abord que va coûter à l'état ce
nouveau confinement alors bercy a fait
des prévisions et on voit que pour un
confinement d'un mois ne sais pas s'il
ne durera qu'un mois il peut durer plus
et bien il y aurait si on fait
l'addition du fonds de solidarité qui
aide les entreprises et les particuliers
le chômage partiel les exemptions
fiscales
il y aurait à peu près 11 milliards
d'euros qui seraient dépensées pour un
confinement d'un mois évidemment s'il
devait durer plus long et bien
l'addition
s'alourdir jacques le coup ce n'est pas
seulement ce que l'état dépense mais
aussi moins de richesses produites et
donc moins d'impôts oui tout à fait vous
avez tout à fait raison c'est fini et là
on va le voir
on a là aussi des estimations qui ont
été faites par bercy qui ont été faites
par la banque de france et on pense
qu'il y aura donc une perte de
croissance d'environ un point de pipe là
d'ici la fin du mois d'avril et le début
du mois de mai après il ya évidemment
les conséquences de cela et on voit très
bien que les recettes fiscales puisqu'il
ya moins d'activités vont baisser et là
encore ça ajoute l'équivalent de 11
milliards d'euros ce qui fait que
globalement la dette et le déficit
budgétaire pour 2021 devrait monter
encore là aussi de l'équivalent d'un
pour cent du pib' alors jacques a dans
ce contexte comment la france se situe
talents en europe
c'est évidemment un point et déjà il ya
un premier décrochage de la france par
rapport à nos voisins directs européens
alors même si les autres pays ont été
tout autant toucher que nous par exemple
en allemagne on parle d'un confinement
on parle d'un durcissement des mesures
sanitaires en italie bref et comme on le
voit là sur le graphique est bien en
réalité la france a été un des pays qui
ont été les plus touchées justement par
la crise du code vide alors ce qui est
quand même extrêmement inquiétant c'est
qu'on voit aussi que la france est un
des pays qui se relève le plus lentement
alors que ce soit par rapport à
l'allemagne
évidemment par rapport à la suède mais
même dans le cas du royaume uni le
royaume uni qui est le seul pays qui a
été en fait en dessous de nous au niveau
de la crise du coc vide assez assez
largement
eh bien il va nous rattraper pourquoi
parceque ils ont une politique de
vaccination qui est beaucoup plus
agressive qui est beaucoup plus réussie
il faut le dire que la france est donc
tout cela se conjugue pour faire que la
france en fait se retrouve avec l'italie
tout à fait en queue de peloton
alors jacques la france est elle aussi
en mauvaise position si on la compare
avec les résultats des autres pays
développés
oui et ça stéphanie c'est quelque chose
qui est aussi extrêmement important
c'est peut-être là où ça se voit de la
manière la plus nette il voulait ce
risque de déclassement qui était un 2e
des classements cette fois ci plus avec
nos voisins européens mais avec les
grands pays développés
alors pourquoi il n'y a pas que la cause
de la crise bien sûr l'aco vide a joué
très largement
mais il ya aussi une mauvaise gestion de
la crise sanitaire et il y a bien
entendu
l'absence des plans de relance alors on
voit là il ya trois problèmes qui se
posent
le premier problème ça a été la
désindustrialisation de la france
l'économie française est aujourd'hui
très largement une économie de services
et c'est ce qui explique que le choc de
la coved et été plus brutal pour nous
par exemple que pour les états unis
évidemment pour le japon pour la russie
pour la corée consacré un premier point
le deuxième point
évidemment ce sont des politiques
sanitaires qui n'ont pas été optimale il
faut bien le dire nos politiques
sanitaires alors bombe
nous avons fait peut-être un peu moins
de bêtises que des pays comme les etats
unis ou comme le brésil mais nous
n'avons pas non plus réussi réellement
les choses et de ce point de vue là le
japon et la corée s'en tire nettement
mieux que nous et puis il ya un
troisième point qui est encore plus
important c'est les mesures de relance
et on voit là que les mesures de relance
que ce soit celles qui ont été prises au
niveau européen où que ce soit celles
qui sont prises à l'échelon français
reste très en deçà de ce qui est fait
alors que ce soit en allemagne
que ce soit aux états unis en
particulier donc c'est pour ça qu'on
peut parler d'un risque de déclassement
par rapport aux grandes puissances alors
jeanne vous aviez aussi parlé dans une
précédente émission du retard que l'on
serait en train de prendre avec l'asie
oui tout à fait et là encore si vous
voulez il ya des choses qui sont très
inquiétantes
alors bien sûr il ya le cas de la chine
qui a connu une virée une réduction de
sa croissance mais qui n'est pas rentré
en récession en 2020 tout comme le
vietnam
mais si on regarde là encore ce
graphique on voit que même si ces pays
ont un niveau de richesse par habitant
qui est inférieur à celui de la france
bon ce qui est pratiquement le cas de
tous ces pays malgré tout la croissance
alors qui est attendu en 2021 mais
encore plus celle qui est attendu pour
2022 2023 ou 2024 va les propulser très
au delà du niveau que la france pourrait
atteindre est donc là encore il ya un
troisième type de décrochage alors
qu'ils n'affectent pas que la france qui
affectera aussi les pays de l'union
européenne par rapport à ce qui va
devenir maintenant de manière tout à
fait évidente
le pôle de croissance du monde c'est à
dire
l'asie orientale et l'extrême orient de
la manière la plus large alors serait
justement des prévisions de croissance
pour 2021 en france est ce que ce sera
le dernier
il faut l'espérer mais ce n'est
malheureusement pas sûr
on voit très bien d'ailleurs comment
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
détermine d'une certaine manière
l'évolution de la situation économique
si jamais il devait y avoir un quatrième
confinement les conséquences en seraient
tout à fait ne tout à fait dramatique et
on voit aussi à quel point la politique
de vaccination joue un rôle très
important pour la reprise dans les pays
qui ont été très touchés par l'épidémie
et est de ce point de vue là on ne peut
que regretter le retard qui a été pris
au niveau français et au niveau européen
d'une certaine manière parce que là de
ce point de vue là nous ne faisons pas
pire que les autres pays de l'union
européenne mais nous faisons très
nettement moins bien que le royaume uni
ou que les états unis et donc si je
comprends bien jacques on est loin
d'être tiré d'affaires hélas oui c'est
vraiment là une question qui est
extrêmement importante la france a été
particulièrement touchée par cette crise
je voulais dit parce que nous payons
d'une certaine manière le prix de 30
années de désindustrialisation et c'est
la raison pour laquelle l'économie
française a été si particulièrement
touchées en particulier si on la compare
par exemple avec l'allemagne qui a été -
qui a été moins touchée alors qu'elle
subit désormais le même niveau de crise
sanitaire que nous alors que la russie
aussi qui a été nettement moins touché
que nous donc ça c'est le premier point
une politique sanitaire qui n'est pas
l'une des meilleures
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire on peut
même dire que on a été mauvais dans
toute une série de questions
et puis surtout cette absence des plans
de relance ou dix ans cette faiblesse
des plans de relance qui risque de
retarder le redémarrage de l'économie
française
et ce sont ces trois raisons d'une
certaine manière qui me font craindre un
décrochage de l'économie française que
ce soit en europe que ce soit par
rapport aux grands pays développés où
que ce soit par rapport à ce qu'on
appelle les pays de l'asie émergente